pascal what is your weakest rate and how
do you work around it writing I know
that's where I'm lacking and I'm open
about it but that's why it that's where
Fred I think it's important to have a
lot of collaborator because if you are
open about knowing your weaknesses and
strengths then you go find the right
people who can help you and I had a
great two three people were super blunt
like yeah that's seen that doesn't work
that's that now that's horrible delete
that riri right that or stuff like that
and but at the same time I know if they
are right or wrong you know it's not
like a surprise oh my god really it's
like yeah I know this one is problem
sometimes it's just hard and again and
go from writing from I'm French and
writing something in English sometimes
the dialogue doesn't flow as well that's
why I give super a big freedom to all my
actors just like take them and make it
your own and and but you need that I
think the biggest thing a director needs
to have is openness about letting others
coming and help you otherwise if you
just close everyone else is gonna make
your work horrible so I had a for
example hitting I had a good good friend
that this guy is just good at editing is
like for him it's math it's just is
right this is tempo that doesn't work
that tempo doesn't work switch this for
him you see all those it's like Tetris
almost you know for him is just move
this move this movie it makes sense and
I see think that I didn't see because
sometimes when you're just too much it's
been four years I'm just you're so
focused you don't see it a month at one
point you just you lose it you don't see
clearly so this guy really helped me for
editing then it has someone else who
helped me with the writing the script as
how yeah even the actors j Darlow she
helped me shizune famous she helped me
in the process to just help me with some
scenes to make it great first of all
earth seen in all of them i was like
look this is the direction i want you to
go improv and we the whole let's say
80's 90's seen in the film it's
everything was improv so because I trust
her it's not just like because I'm weak
now it's like I trust you this is the
direction I want you to go i want you to
talk about 80's 90's here's some
guidelines that I don't go for it and
but yeah you need to be able to have
this open mind
about people to let to make your project
better so yes I work with few people but
I make sure that these two people can
really help me and it's gonna be the
same thing for an index 1 i'm going to
go get better help in some department to
make it even better better sound design
better writing and stuff like that just
to step it up and does the whole point
you need to evolve and need to be aware
that everything is going to get better
do you feel then that the 30 films that
you did the shorts were I mean you said
you're wasting your time I know you you
just kind of threw that out as a comment
like throwaway comment sort of but but
it sounds like that was actually
beneficial because then you got to a
point where you knew what to let go of
and what to let others help you with
yeah totally and even in the short for
me I think it's the best way to just
practice practice in your writing
practice in your directing and I've
always said that if it's forced it's not
going to come out good and my 3 best
short film was under isin white blossom
and something in the way and all those
film was done in three hours and it was
a written on the fly and it worked that
was my best writing sometimes it's just
work when it's forced and you feel that
it's like it's not working it's not
working then it means that something is
not working so you need to be aware of
that and just really try to get the help
and see different point of view of
people why doesn't work and then after
that it's just going to be easier to see
a clearer picture did you trust the
people that you got the feedback from I
mean these are people that you know well
because because it sounds like after a
while you kind of said well I believe in
them so I should probably yeah and at
the same time that everyone is going to
have an opinion so you have to filter a
little bit but those are close people
that for example the guy we helped me
hitting his name is Mark and it's just I
know that is amazing on this he's not
great at other stuff but for this he was
the best and for with me I'm sure later
I'm gonna work with more professional
people I'm gonna have whatever you know
you step it up but you you deal with
what you have around you and the people
that you totally trust and you know
they're gonna they're not there to kiss
your ass a little bit you know they were
there to say yeah you suck on this you
suck and that's just work better try
better go just realize what work doesn't
work but it there
I know they were doing it with love and
those comfort really helps you to be
better because you know those people are
there to to make you better and they
believe in the project and it believed
in you and they want you to succeed
they're not here to just pass you do you
think a director should be careful and
having yes people around them no I don't
in some degrees in a way yeah no I don't
want yes people I want people that was
gonna be blood but I want them to be
blunt in a positive way sure don't be
negative like like first of all Tyler it
was always positive and when something
didn't work it was not like you suck i
don't know it was just like yeah i don't
think it work i think what you did was
great but i think if we try this
direction i think we can find them about
where something was just do you think
that it's working he says now I don't
know it doesn't work like yeah I think
that thing is I think it's my fault
let's find this dis dis or what about
this then is that hole yeah that's way
better now he's gonna try it so no you
don't want us people you want you want
how can we make it better people that's
this one because yes people are just
like oh my god Pascal is that's so great
what you've done okay but you're gonna
always gonna remember the guy who says
yeah that seems suck you know right but
then there's a difference there's those
that want to hold your head under water
and then there's none ones that want you
to know your air so that but you can
filter that you know you know them when
of those people just say yeah pass got
that sucker a screw you you know right I
know you're just jealous or you because
I know you're trying to make a family
does it work for you and maybe you're
jealous that I did something so but
those people who just wants you to
succeed they're gonna give you it's
gonna be constructive it's going to be
positive and is going to be there to
help you and you're going to take the
time to sit down with you and make it
better and so that now I love that
that's the thing i love that it makes
even if i love to be lonely and do all
my stuff alone I love having those
people again I'm just very specific and
everything needs to be mated mystic and
you love the melancholy feel of a story
I love nothing but do you love 80's
Happy's happy fella know what what would
that's interesting what where does the
the love for this melancholy for your
frequent music wise i love gothic rock
and gothic rock it's all about
melancholy deep pain of love and
stuff like that I don't know it just
connects with me and I've tried to bring
that and i'm not a big IP ending guy i'm
more of a melancholy all of those kind
of feeling that lifts you like but
there's some hope and the short film was
about that it was about a big pain but
it was about a struggle but now she's
trying to lift a little bit in be
stronger the same thing for on the
horizon the same thing for my short
white blossom it was about people who
just think about beauty but it was just
the whole vibe is melancholic with the
music with the colors would be editing
the slow pace and the beauty and I don't
know it's just something that uh that
connects with me and love was always the
big discussion in my films that's
something that that I because they
always say write what you know and love
in relationship that's what I've been
kind of a good at for the past that's
what I've been working with for the past
15 years I've been dealing with so many
relationship love ate whatever so many
levels of relationships so of you I'm
pushing this into my film unrequited
love exactly
you